[Music]
welcome back
so in the last video we talked all about
partial differential equations what they
are what they do and we give a number of
canonical pdes that we can use to
understand kind of physical phenomena
like how traveling waves travel how heat
diffuses
steady-state heat distributions things
like that
and today i'm going to zoom in on
laplace's equation which is one of my
absolute favorite and one of the most uh
useful equations in all of physics okay
from gravitation to fluid flow
electrostatics uh thermal dynamics it's
super useful almost everywhere and
actually laplace's equation is one of
those cases
where
it's really really useful for motivating
things like the fourier transform so
that's a very very useful
perspective
now before i jump in i want to give a
quick recap of what we talked about in
partial differential equations
and i hope you can tell how much i love
pdes
because they give us a language of
writing down what we observe in the
world so the world around us is changing
and it's changing in time and in space
so if you look at uh the elastic waves
on the earth during an earthquake if you
look at uh galaxies colliding if you
look at
you know the waves crashing on the beach
these are
systems where the state of the system
the function the state of the system u
is changing in space and in time
and these partial differential equations
allow us to codify or encode physics
that we know about the system into an
equation that we can analyze and solve
to use this to predict
what will happen in the future what will
happen for other parameters
and so
the pde is usually written in terms of
some function u which we think of as the
state of the system
uh this could be the temperature in a
plate as a function of of space and time
in which case i would have the heat
equation as the pde that describes the
governing physics
and so that function u is normally what
we're trying to solve for so we have a
partial differential equation that we
write down from physics or we derive
from physics and we're trying to solve
for u as a function of x and t so we
know what the state of our system will
be for example at a future time
or at a different place in space
now what i didn't mention
is that to actually solve these things
you absolutely need initial conditions
you need to know what the initial state
of your system is at time zero and you
need to know what boundary conditions
you have you need to know kind of what
is happening on the boundaries if i have
a plate of metal and i want to know its
temperature distribution i need to know
what are the temperatures at the edges
are they insulated are is one edge in a
cold bath and the other edge is in a hot
bath
those are important for the solution
but the goal here is to solve for this
function that i care about whether it's
a temperature distribution this u could
be a vector of functions u1 u2 u3
for the velocity flu field of a fluid
which is another thing i'm often
interested in solving for and we solve
these pdes for those variables
now these partial differential equations
we're going to see this in laplace's
equation we already actually have seen
this
these encode things i want my solution
to
satisfy
so for example
in many systems i know that i have
conservation of mass
conservation of momentum linear and
angular and conservation of energy
and so for example in a fluid flow i can
write down the conservation of momentum
and i can using like gauss's theorem or
stokes's theorem using my vector
calculus identities i can derive a
partial differential equation that has
to be satisfied
uh for momentum to be conserved in that
uh in that physics and in that case you
actually derive the navy or stokes
equations those are the partial
differential equations for mass constant
for momentum conservation in a fluid
uh and similarly the heat equation is
the conservation of thermal energy um
and and the list goes on and on your
conservation laws result in partial
differential equations that you can then
solve for a solution so just
fantastically cool um you know almost
all of the physics that have been
characterized over the last few hundred
years has resulted in a partial
differential equation
which we think of as the governing
equation the law of nature for that
particular conservation law
mass momentum energy and so on and so
forth
today we're going to talk about
laplace's equation um and laplace's
equation we're going to write it down as
the laplace operator of some function
phi
equals zero again this function phi is
the the state function i care about we
sometimes we call it a potential
function or a harmonic function if it
satisfies laplace's equation so this
harmonic function
and
we've already shown that these fees can
be very very useful for getting gradient
flow fields vector fields which are the
gradient of phi that are irrotational
and incompressible so potential flows
and in fact i'm actually just going to
write this out so
this
solution fee here essentially gives you
a potential that you can use to make a
gradient field
so this is
an incompressible
gradient
field uh gradient field
fee
and the way i think about that this
laplacian operator is actually
you know del squared
of phi is equal to the divergence of the
gradient of the scalar function phi
so essentially
gradient fields are always irrotational
they always have curl zero that's a
vector identity you can check out
yourself so the curl of any gradient
field is always zero it's always
irrotational
but if we also specify that we want this
gradient flow to be incompressible so
its divergence equals zero
that's the same thing as saying that the
laplacian of that potential fee has to
be zero so laplace's equation
essentially gives us these
incompressible gradient flow fields uh
grad fee okay we already saw this in
potential flow
what i want to do today
is write down a number of the physical
systems where laplace's equation comes
up okay
so i'll just do that right now
so the first example is going to be
gravitation
so this kind of uh gravitational
potential and this is really important i
want to i can't emphasize this enough
when i talk about gravitation and
electrostatics i am talking about the
the field or the vector field away from
point masses and point charges so for
example if i am free falling
towards earth
i can use this gravitational potential
but the minute i hit a point mass you
know things are a little bit different
so so we assume that we're kind of in a
free space away from actual masses we're
in the solar system moving around and we
think of jupiter and the sun and the
earth and the moon you know all the
planets as point masses and away from
those point masses uh the gravitational
potential satisfies laplace's equation
okay good um
so this is a way
from mass
those masses are kind of like
singularities in this potential
and so um how do i want to draw this
i'll just actually draw like a little
you know earth with all of its uh
gravitational potential fields and we
know that the potential
um you know is a function of the the
distance away from the earth so it has
this kind of uh spherical symmetry
and we know that our potential
f
so our vector field our force field you
know newton's
law of gravitation our force field is
minus gradient
of this vector potential where v equals
uh minus m
of the little point let's say i'm a
little point out here with little m
the planet has big m
um
gravitational constant divided by my
radius
to that mass okay this is my my
potential function v
it's a function of three variables x y
and z or r theta and phi whatever
coordinates you want this is a three
dimensional potential
but it's a scalar potential of these
three spatial coordinates
and it establishes a vector field that
satisfies laplace's equation away from
point masses so you can essentially
verify so verify
that
laplacian of v equals zero away from
point masses
good okay gravitation that's one really
really good example
and similarly we know that
electrostatics kind of coulomb's law is
almost identical to newton's law so of
course this is also going to be true
for
electrostatics
electrostatic and electrostatic
potential
so if you open up you know kind of
jackson's e m or griffiths e m you're
going to be looking a lot at the
laplace's equation for these
electrostatic potentials you're going to
learn techniques to find
you know a basis of solutions that you
can add up to to kind of get more
complicated uh
electrostatic potentials if there's lots
of different point masses or
distributions of sorry point charges and
distributions of point charges
things like that
and so similarly you know if i draw this
in blue
we have
kind of these
every charge and again away from any
charge
my field is going to satisfy laplace's
equation
so this is fundamentally similar kind of
coulomb's law
is very similar
gravitation
and i'm not going to go any farther than
that it's basically gravitation but with
you know now these masses they're you
know opposites attract same signs repel
so it's you know just a sign difference
okay two really really really important
like whole textbooks big big textbooks
on you know electrostatics on
gravitation
all governed by
laplace's equation away from
a point charge or point mass
another area probably my favorite where
i learned about laplace's equation and
really where i learned about partial
differential equations in fact where
modern pdes a lot of them came from if
you ask my opinion
is heat conduction
so this is another one of the main
applications of laplace's equation heat
conduction
uh heat conduction and specifically i
mean steady state heat conduction steady
state
heat conduction and so in steady state
heat conduction what we're going to do
is we are going to say that we have a
temperature t
t equals the temperature
and this is t is the temperature in some
object this could be a thin metal rod
like a wire a power cable it could be
the temperature in a 2d plate of metal
it could be the temperature distribution
on the the nose cone of a you know
satellite
or or rocket or you know a vehicle
re-entering the earth's atmosphere it
could be the temperature distribution of
some object we care about
and uh specifically so we know that the
heat equation i'm just going to write
this down we have partial t
partial
partial little t the derivative of
temperature with respect to time
is equal to a positive constant alpha
squared
times the laplacian operator of my
temperature
and i'm going to derive this in one of
these lectures we're actually going to
derive this from conservation of thermal
energy again conservation laws are how
we get pdes using vector calculus using
gauss's theorem essentially and vector
calculus we will derive this so just
take it for granted
uh and in steady state
steady state meaning that when when when
the temperature distribution stops
changing
we have that
laplacians of t
has to equal zero in steady
state
so if i have you know some uh
thin metal rod and it's insulated on the
ends and i hit it with a blow torch in
the middle so i give it some you know
some forcing
the steady state temperature
distribution will satisfy laplace's
equation
this is super super useful um if i don't
have the blow torch solution this will
approach a constant
a constant solution
and then the fourth example that we
talked about and we've already seen a
lot of this is
incompressible
irrotational flows incompressible
irrotational
flows
these are so-called potential pot
potential flows
where i have a vector field that equals
the gradient of phi where phi satisfies
laplace's equation so this is a very
useful category of fluid flows that we
use uh you know to design aircraft and
things like that
okay so even just one of these simple
canonical pdes have all of these
different major applications in physics
and so it really should motivate us to
try to understand how to solve laplace's
equation and how to build up that
mathematical architecture
to look at the solutions of this and
again like i mentioned before
because this is a linear partial
differential equation
meaning that these derivatives act as
linear operators on fee
it means that linear superposition holds
so if i have two solutions of this phi 1
and phi 2 or two temperature
distributions t1 and t2
and i add those up
that will also be a solution of
laplace's equation okay so two solutions
add up there's still a solution
and so what that allows us to do is try
to find kind of a basis of eigen
solutions like this infinite family of
orthogonal solutions
so that i can add them up in different
combinations to get particular solutions
for a particular boundary condition and
initial condition things like that
and this will actually be a lot like
what we do in ordinary differential
equations where we diagonalize
our our linear ode into eigenvector
coordinates we can diagonalize this
equation into eigenfunction coordinates
and it turns out that the eigenfunctions
are going to be our fourier sine and
cosine functions so that's how fourier
derived his fourier transform was
essentially to diagonalize this heat
equation okay and so
this is a really really really important
set of concepts and this is the building
block to almost all of modern
quantitative
physics where things depend on space and
on time okay last thing i want to show
you is poisson's equation so laplace's
equation
uh if you force laplace's equation then
you get poisson's equation it sounds
super cool it's a little fishy if you
ask me
this just says that you have laplace's
equation
del squared phi
but instead of equaling zero this equals
some forcing f so where
f is uh a forcing function
and this forcing function could be um
a function of space a function of time
uh it could be that i'm you know that's
my blow torch on my my
uh
thermal plate on my metal plate this
could be the the forcing function that
i'm i'm hitting it with a blow torch now
what's the steady state distribution so
this is just a source term
um
and it turns out the poisson's equation
and laplace's equation are
computationally used all the time when
you want to solve a fluid flow equation
the navy or stokes equation it's much
more complicated than just laplace or
just uh poisson or just the wave
equation it's a non-linear partial
differential equation that has some
diffusion and some nonlinear convection
and things like that
but often how we solve it there is a
step where we solve poisson's equation
so we like lump everything you know into
this f function and we try to solve for
this fee using using poisson's equation
this is often one of the most expensive
steps
in solving fluid flow equations on a
computer the navy or stokes equations
and so it's interesting that there's
actually a lot of effort trying to build
new machine learning algorithms and new
computational algorithms in general to
speed up the solution of poisson's
equation
so it seems like it's kind of a simple
simple equation here we know it's linear
we know it has you know relationship to
all of these these types of physics so
if i force
my my electrostatic system then i get
poisson's equation
but it actually is still very very
relevant even for modern high
performance computing of non-linear
partial differential equations as well
okay pdes are amazing powerful
expressive ways of representing physics
and conservation laws and this is just
one example of a very special pde
laplace's equation with tons of examples
in science and engineering all right
thank you